[Music]
do you see that
yeah
coming together there's a logical
explanation it's a ghost
what
so we're dealing with a uh
ghost writer
my pocket watch has stopped if you don't
mind i'd appreciate the time there's a
talking rabbit that nobody can see but
us i think the ghost who was sending us
messages also sent us the rabbit
this way
you're gonna think this is bizarre but
what if your grandma's ghost rider she
did bring us all together grandpa said
even though grandma's gone she'll always
be with us
your grandma had this old letter she
even kept it in a fancy box secret
letter
did y'all say you need help find
something cause i'm real good at finding
stuff
i don't think grandma wanted anyone to
find this
until now
the letter was signed s
who's s
[Applause]
what was that
a clue from ghostwriter follow what
follow the money
check if we can see the signature we'll
know if that guy is us you knew reuben's
grandma she was sure that this bookstore
was haunted so if your grandma knew
there was a ghost in the bookstore
then maybe she's not the ghost
[Music]
whoa gw's painting
cobalt mask
there's no author on here
that's a first
[Music]
this is gonna be interesting
rumor has it there's an unpublished
mason breaks manuscript
that's ghostwriter he's back
maybe it's number the storage unit
this must be the typewriter he used to
write the manuscript what else can be
written on a typewriter
[Music]
a secret letter
mason briggs wrote this letter to my
grandma
mason breaks is a made-up name you are
correct mason briggs is a pseudonym
i can't believe we hit another dead end
[Music]
ew don't touch random things on the
subway
check it out this newspaper's from the
future
everything in this book has built at
this moment
high stakes and full of suspense
[Music]
can you believe gw sending us on a time
travel mystery
yes i can
you